leute was war das denn viele viele
nachrichten haben mich auf whatsapp
erreicht und ja auch für mich war es
eines der bewegendsten ereignisse meines
lebens wir haben gestern im wahrsten
sinne des wortes die nächste stufe der
raumfahrt erlebt das war wirklich
unglaublich und wenn wir heute erfahren
dass der chor das zentrale element der
ersten stufe nicht auf dem spaceport den
chip gelandet ist dann ist das nur eine
randnotiz gestern wurde wirklich die
menschheitsgeschichte neu geschrieben
und das hat ihnen mass geschafft jetzt
also alle details und ein paar
verblüffende news zum start der fall wie
bei kik zum science fiction herzlich
willkommen bei den allen masc chroniken
etwa aussieht viele landung von falken
stufen auf dem space pop duo chip of
course a view durch die große hitze und
dem starken strahl der triebwerke fielen
die kameras vor ort schon öfter aus doch
dieses mal ist die erste stufe der korb
tatsächlich nicht auf der landeplattform
aufgesetzt nur einmal in 1 d triebwerk
hatte gebündelt und so reichte der schub
nicht für eine korrekte landung aus die
stufen viel ins meer und ist verloren
aber was soll's das ist wirklich nur
noch eine randnotiz eine kleinigkeit was
wir gestern erlebt haben ist ein
meilenstein in der menschheitsgeschichte
jetzt gibt es zumindest gefühlt nahezu
keine grenzen mehr
bemannte raumflüge zum mars und anderen
planeten in unserem sonnensystem sind
jetzt keine hirngespinste mehr
die falcon heavy ist aktuell das größte
raumschiff der erde und zeigt als
zwischenstufe zum nächstgrößeren schiff
wohin die reise geht im wahrsten sinne
des wortes zahlreiche neuigkeiten gab es
dann im anschluss von ihnen muss zuhören
und man hätte es sich denken können
dabei waren einige verblüffende
informationen das fängt schon mit dem
raumanzug des paceman an es ist nicht
nur irgendeine verkleidung nein im
geheimen hatte allen masc einen eigenen
smarten und leichten raumanzug
entwickelt und gestern hatte er seinen
jungfernflug edel maas hatte seinen
tesla also nicht mit einem höchst
verkleideten spaceman ins all geschickt
sondern das was wir gestern gesehen
haben war ohne dass wir es ahnen konnten
der test eines neuen alltagstauglichen
absolut spektakulären raumanzugs
verglichen mit den aktuellen klobigen
modellen ist auch eher mal so ganz
nebenbei ein großer schritt eine
bahnbrechende innovation in der
raumfahrt zitat das ist das einzig wahre
das sagt mast wir haben drei jahre lang
gebraucht um diesen welt drauf anzug zu
entwerfen
man kann einfach in einer vakuumkammer
springen und es ist in ordnung ja wer
genau hinschaut wird zudem etwas
ziemlich verrücktes auf dem
armaturenbrett des tesla roadsters
entdecken
zumindest beschreibt es so wenn du auf
das armaturenbrett guckst ist da ein
kleiner tesla roadster mit einem kleinen
spaceman erklärt was tatsächlich hat in
einem us ein kleines hot wheels auto auf
dem armaturenbrett befestigt und einen
mini paceman herr eingesetzt auf diese
idee muss man erst mal kommen
zitat es ist irgendwie albern ist lustig
aber ich denke das alberne und lustige
dinge wichtig sind ich denke die bilder
sind etwas was die leute auf der ganzen
welt begeistern wird
und das ist auch wohl so ein um die erde
fliegen
spaceman in einem tesla roadster so was
habe ich mir wirklich nicht evander
wildesten fantasie vorstellen können ich
bin wirklich absolut hin und weg und es
gab weitere news die dragon kapsel die
astronauten ins all fliegen kann ist
nahezu fertig zitat wir wollen ende des
jahres eine kuh in den orbit fliegen
sagte maske und auch zur big falken
rocket zur bfh gab es neuigkeiten macht
sagte diez vom bfh könnten in diesem
jahr auf dem testgelände von spacex in
texas beginnen
beginnend mit hopper flügen dabei wird
das schiff mehrere kilometer in die
atmosphäre geschossen und wieder
gelandet jammers gab keine zeitpläne für
möglichen missionen zum mond oder mars
bekannt aber er sagte dass ein eher tor
wird es für die bfa erst in drei bis
vier jahren geplant sein damit wir
kennen es vom mast hat er mal wieder die
pläne verschoben die beiden frachtflüge
zum mars bereits 2022 sind damit nicht
mehr möglich aber was da gestern geschah
war absolut mein bloggen und ob das
jetzt etwas länger dauert oder nicht das
ist glaube ich vollkommen egal musk hat
den traum der menschheit zur eroberung
des weltraums dem hat er wieder neuen
schub gegeben
ja im wahrsten sinne des wortes ist es
absolut phänomenal und ich werde glaube
ich noch ein paar tage gänsehaut haben
gleich ist bei euch auch so wenn es
etwas neues zum thema gibt und damit
rechne ich in den nächsten tagen und ihr
dazu keine news verpassen wollt und auch
zu allen anderen themen dann meldet euch
hierbei whatsapp an und natürlich auch
nicht das abo vergessen mit der genau
dann erfahrt ihr also bei whatsapp
erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen vom
neuesten video garantiert ihr könnt dort
direkt in der redaktion von pixum
mitmachen und themen vorschlagen oder
fragen zu videos stimmt der direkte
draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken
und natürlich nicht ich habe es gerade
gesagt das aber mit der glocke vergessen
ist habe ich das einzige wie du mit zwei
paukenschlägen also hier geht es weiter
mit dafür drauf klicken
als erster staat dafür wie die größte
rakete der welt der livestream da
bekommt man noch mal die
gänsehaut-momente mit ansonsten würde
ich mal sagen bis dann bleib dran